réunir littérature et patrimoine le
temps d'une journée les amis du passé
d'elancourt nous fait dimanche 22
octobre la commanderie des templiers de
la villedieu a accueilli le premier
salon du livre des langues
ils étaient une cinquantaine d'exposants
dans ce haut lieu du patrimoine local
l'occasion pour les auteurs de partager
leurs histoires et leurs passions comme
prisca ancien claudette auprès de claude
françois dans les années 70 je suis là
pour partager avec qui veut bien la lire
mon histoire avec claude j'ai eu la
chance de travailler avec mon idole
pendant cinq ans les cinq dernières
années j'ai on dit toujours que le
bonheur c'est de réaliser ses rêves
d'enfant eh bien j'ai réalisé mon rêve
en forme et monique de son côté a
réalisé un long travail de recherches
auprès des archives de coignières avant
de publier ces ouvrages qui retrace
l'histoire de la vie ces deux livres
j'ai écrit avec bonheur mais
je pense que ça il faut le faire
connaître sur coignières tout le monde
le connaît maintenant il faut le faire
connaître un peu ailleurs
j'ai demandé 20 livres de chaque tome
et tous mes droits d'auteur les
abandonner à la mairie bande dessinée
biographie bouquin géopolitique et
historique
le choix était large pour le plus grand
plaisir des visiteurs
je trouve ça génial je dirais que
avec ça se renouvelle un peu plus
souvent pour plein de raisons je tends
je pense que les gens nous disent passer
on est tous sur nos ordinateurs nos
enfants nos petits-enfants je pense que
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui a
besoin d'être ramenés au devant de la
scène en 2016 53% des français ont
acheté au moins un livre un chiffre
stable depuis deux années consécutives